ross today's our big halloween show
you want to help me carve this okay
whoa what what's going on behind those
doors
um
i am not sure because the rest of the
crew isn't supposed to be here for
another hour
maybe it's ghosts or a murderer or a
bird or hornets
well
where do you think that this goes rossi
i have no clue
i can't help but go into it hold me drew
i'm scared hold
it's the drew barrymore show and it's
halloween 2051 someplace east of the
milky way
please welcome through barrymore and
ross matthews
thank you so much
for coming here
we're starting drew's news here we go
how are we today is everyone feeling
good
i'm so glad that you guys all showed up
this is such wonderful news i love your
glasses
we all look fantastic i'm so happy to be
here roth hello i'm feeling gorgeous
thank you so much
do are we floating in space right elon
musk are you there
drew oh my god your face
what
you've got wrinkles
well yeah i aged naturally oh
how dare you
ross you look good too
um thank you for noticing yeah
you look like one of those
horses that got cold well turns out they
still got botox in the future so yay
and i remain filler-free yay
[Music]
[Applause]
drew i'll take your leftovers thank you
so much yeah i'll take some of my fat
and you can inject it into those lips
okay wow this is so exciting the future
and
our planet
is still here we're all alive and well
isn't that really wonderful
it's the year 2051 and we're thriving
yeah but i will say that i noticed there
still are no flying cars which makes me
furious weren't we promised flying cars
in the future yeah that's what the
movies would have let us think i gotta
say the future looks good the future
does look good
well thank you that's it for drew's news
of the future but ross
i see those yellow doors acting up again
oh no oh my gosh shall we see where it
takes us next let's do it okay
we'll see you right after the break
everybody
[Applause]
night 1985. welcome to our 80s preteen
bedroom i just watched flash dance last
night what did you watch uh i watched uh
footloose and terms of endearment i'm
still crying that's what i call a double
feature
oh my gosh
wow the yellow doors are doing it again
i wonder what decade they're gonna take
us to next i don't know but i'm
intrigued
[Applause]
it's halloween
1951
this year i love lucy premiered on
television
guess what else happened the first
direct dial coast to coast telephone
call was made wow i know think about
that when you get irritated with your
cell phone i wonder what decade our
doors will take us to next
stay with us to find out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
well we're in the 90s and we look like
we're all that in a bag of chips that's
right we're kicking it grunge style i
mean who doesn't love the sound of
dial up internet
[Applause]
trying to decide which spice girl we're
gonna kick it with back in an episode of
saved by the bell ross do you think the
1990s are de bomb the 90s were amazing
say by the bell 902.0 melrose place
member everyone
the bomb
we used to have parties at my house um
pizza parties and like you know wine and
beer and hang out and watch a double
feature of 90210 and melrose place yes
and leonardo dicaprio would come over
sometimes you try what do you what are
you trying to do to me like all he was
friends with all of my friends so like
sometimes there'd just be leo kicking it
on the couch from melrose place now um
your parties were a little bit cooler
than mine
what the doors they're at again oh no
are you scared a little i'm thrilled
let's check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to our totally awesome show
we had a radical time yeah that's right
and we'll catch you on the flip side of
that 45.
[Music]
don't flip your lids but we're out of
time but we'll see all your nifty guys
and dollies again soon booyah hope your
halloween is da bomb and get jiggy with
your home skillet yeah if not take a
chill pill man and talk to the hand
happy halloween bleep floor
thank you for choosing to spend your
time with us and we hope you take it
with you
[Music]